here now with reaction we have Fox News
contributors kellyanne Conway Ari fler
with us uh they were able to call this
literally you know within seconds within
seconds the largest margin that any
previous Republican candidate had won by
was Bob Dole which was 12.8% yes um
looks like this is going to be a much
wider margin tonight um what are your
expectations what is this do for
president Trump what impact will it have
on Governor DeSantis Nikki Haley in
terms of the battle for second look I
know there's a battle for second but if
you look at Trump's dominance across
pretty much every cross tab group he won
he's going to win young people first
time caucus goers he's going to dominate
among Evangelical Christians among women
hello Nikki you name it Trump is
dominating it's a fullscale victory for
him tonight Sean whether he gets to 50%
or not it doesn't matter so what's my
expectation for them that they they can
carry on but I feel like tonight Trump
got got win play show I mean that the
they're so far behind him and I think
when you go into a state like South
Carolina which is winner take all where
Nikki Haley was the governor a while ago
now uh that's where Jeb Bush and others
fell out of the race because Trump got I
think he got about a third of the vote
the raw vote but he got all 42 delegates
coming out of South Carolina in the
third contest in 2016 this feels like
2016 in terms of the Trump hunger
Swagger being counted down counted out
Underdog underestimated but not
underfunded and under staff this time
yet it's 2016 Trump with the 2017 to
2020 record president Trump it's a very
unique position you were there what is
been very very apparent to me is the
organization yes fantastic which was
non-existent I think you can argue or
fairly non-existent no offense to the
people that worked in 2016 on his Iowa
campaign but compared Now versus then
night and day wasn't it no Ivanka told
me the story of her and Jared opening up
folding tables and folding chairs trying
to help when she was very pregnant at
the time with her third child uh just
trying to organize actual caucus areas
and volunteer table so yes this was very
different I think Susie wilds and the
team left nothing to chance they put a
great G ground game together this I this
Trump caucus Captain hat I think is a
great collector's item but sha and the
others went to the airwaves and all
these third-party groups coming in late
for Nikki Haley they chose yeah to knock
on doors a little bit but really to go
to the airwaves and it's just not going
to bear as much fruit look you said
something important at the top you are
discussing the Trump detractors the
Trump haters the never trumpers they
look so ridiculous time after time it's
always the wheels coming off the bus
this is the time we're going to get
Donald Trump where most voters are
looking at this and saying we need to
you know we need to get our country back
on track energy Independence the
homeless out of our cities crime that's
spiraling the prices out of control the
Border 8 million people larger than the
population 10 now we're moving to 10 and
so that's what people are saying and yet
I think if people had spent a fraction
of the time that they spent obsessing
over Trump on understanding the Trump
voter then they may be competitive for
Biden but they're not and I think one of
the best things that ever happened to
Donald Trump is Joe Biden people he con
he contrasts his record to Joe Biden's
record and people are seeing that now
he's been in a general election strategy
I think since last summer uh calling on
calling on Biden uh not just making fun
of his agility and ability that's easy
to do but calling him out on the
Afghanistan withdrawal calling him out
on killing the Keystone Pipeline jobs
calling him out on him and his homeland
security director not even willing to
call the order a crisis which everyone
believes it is including a number of
democratic members of Congress and
governors really challenging Joe Biden I
think there are Democrats out there who
would love to run against Joe Biden but
instead I predict they're going to watch
Joe Biden and K Harris bleed out let
Trump win it and I think Trump who got
blamed 14 short months ago unfairly in
the midterms is the best chance the
Republican party has to flip the Senate
and retain and grow the house I actually
believe a lot of that was based on
abortion it was based on abortion and we
had some crappy candidates you get
Trump's endorsement and you can't fall
asleep you have to do what he does you
have to show up put up can't fall sleep
and run a campaign no know that his
endorsement is not enough it's the
ground not the ceiling you have to go
run your own campaign he's not running
for governor of this state or senator
from that state hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else